[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing voldemort albus dumbledore
and the curse placed on dumbledore after
the destruction of the resurrection
stone and marvolo gaunt's ring
during dumbledore's investigation into
voldemort's horcruxes
he deduced that the gaunt shack in
little hangleton could be a good place
to search for horcruxes
given its significance in voldemort's
past when he found the shack
dumbledore successfully got past the
enchantments protecting the shack
and discovered a golden box holding a
ring marvolo gaunt's ring
upon inspection of the ring dumbledore
recognized the symbol of the deathly
hallows on the ringed black stone
and recognized it as the resurrection
stone something for which dumbledore had
searched
for the greater part of his life with
hopes of reviving dead family members
particularly his sister ariana he was
suddenly blind to the ring's status as a
horcrux
and put it on his hand this of course
released the deadly curse of marvolo
gaunt's ring
and the curse quickly began to spread
throughout dumbledore's body
starting with the hand that he placed
the ring on after realizing what the
ring had done to him
he used the sword of godric gryffindor
which was imbued in basilisk's venom
to destroy the ring and crack the
resurrection stone destroying it as a
horcrux
however the destruction of the ring did
not mean that dumbledore was cured from
the effects of the curse
and it continued to spread throughout
his body when inflicted by the curse
it was obvious that something was wrong
with dumbledore his life force had been
affected
and something was clearly wrong with his
hand so given that dumbledore was so
obviously cursed
it seems reasonable to assume that
voldemort might have been able to
recognize
what had happened to him by seeing
dumbledore shouldn't voldemort have
known what had happened to his horcrux
surely if voldemort had caught on then
this would have complicated things
as voldemort would have become aware of
the fact that his horcruxes were being
targeted
there are a few issues with this first
the curse on dumbledore's hand
may not have been something that
voldemort was even familiar with
there is lots of dark magic in the
magical world and many of it preceded
lord voldemort though he was
knowledgeable and powerful
it's highly unlikely that he knew
everything there was to know about dark
magic
and to assume that he would recognize
every curse is unreasonable
the wrappings fell open the face was
translucent
pale sunken yet almost perfectly
preserved
they had left his spectacles on the
crooked nose he felt amused
derision dumbledore's hands were folded
upon his chest
and there it lay clutched beneath them
buried with him
had the old fool imagined that marble or
death would protect the wand
had he thought the dark lord would be
too scared to violate his tomb
the spider-like hand swooped and pulled
the wand from dumbledore's grasp
and as he took it a shower of sparks
flew from its tip
sparkling over the corpse of its last
owner ready to serve a new master at
last
the excerpt above depicts voldemort
violating dumbledore's tomb
and his acquisition of the elder wand it
paints a clear visual picture
of dumbledore's hands folded upon his
chest and it's never indicated that
voldemort even noticed his hands
what this tells us is that the curse of
nominal's hand was never something that
voldemort had even considered
he had no idea what had happened to
dumbledore and even if voldemort did
notice the curse
he would have just assumed that it was
from something completely unrelated to
him
additionally before seeing dumbledore in
his tomb the last time that voldemort
saw dumbledore was when he dueled him in
the ministry of magic
which was at the end of book five this
was before dumbledore had acquired the
stone
which occurred sometime between books
five and six so voldemort would have
never actually seen
a live dumbledore suffering from the
curse voldemort was also far too
arrogant and even if he had seen
demordor alive
and suffering from the curse he never
would have made the connection to his
horcruxes
i believe not i believe that voldemort
is now so immersed in evil
and these crucial parts of himself have
been attached for so long
he does not feel as we do perhaps at the
point of death
he might be aware of his loss and that's
it for this video
if you enjoy the content please be sure
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel
as always leave your video suggestions
down below
until next time you're a wizard harry
you